[Musica]
buonasera a tutti sono valerio rossi
albertini sono un fisico e quindi vi
posso confermare quello che già sapete
la temperatura del pianeta sta
aumentando il suo riscaldamento globale
che prima era stato ipotizzato dagli
scienziati è stato confermato al di là
di ogni dubbio ragionevole è l'effetto
serra
ma io sfiderei a domandare a chiunque se
abbia consapevolezza di che cos'è
l'effetto serra
vi voglio dimostrare che l'effetto serra
lo conosciamo tutti quanti oggi è una
bella giornata di sole ma è freddo fuori
allora immaginiamo che questa sia la
vostra auto parcheggiata sotto il sole
fuori fa freddo siete intirizziti ma
quando entrate nell'abitacolo a causa
dell'effetto serra
sentirete un bel tempo rino un bel
calduccio confortante che cosa è
successo
ve lo dimostro questa sia la luce del
sole
questa è l'abitacolo vedete che la luce
passa attraverso il parabrezza
attraverso i finestrini e va all'interno
dell'abitacolo
lì la luce del sole che è energia viene
trasformata in un altra forma di energia
nel calore con la differenza però che
mentre la luce è riuscita a penetrare
all'interno il calore non riesce più a
fuoriuscire all'esterno e quindi tende
ad accumularsi e la temperatura aumenta
progressivamente questo è l'effetto
serra in piccola scala
prendiamo il nostro pianeta ecco qua lo
rappresento in questa maniera
un emisfero ma disgraziatamente vale
anche per l'altro a causa delle attività
produttive noi stiamo immettendo un gas
l'anidride carbonica soprattutto o per i
ben parlanti la co2 che sta svolgendo
una funzione analoga a quella del
parabrezza della macchina
immaginiamo che l'anidride carbonica sia
questo velo trasparente che adesso si
trova
sulla superficie del pianeta la luce del
sole riesce a penetrare attraverso il
velo trasparente ma il problema è che
quando è convertito in calore toccando
la superficie terrestre quello stesso
calore non è più in grado di sfuggire
perché rimane imprigionato
questo è l'effetto serra planetario
l'effetto serra è uno degli effetti di
che cosa di uno sviluppo industriale un
pò scriteriato un po dissennato che non
è stato fatto seguendo un piano
regolatore ma seguendo l'abbiamo sentito
un modello di sviluppo che in realtà è
stato inventato nell'ottocento inglese
si chiama economia lineare l'economia
lineare è uno schema in cui esiste una
testa un inizio di questo processo che
el estrazione dal sottosuolo dei
prodotti che occorrono per lavorare i
materiali e per produrre i beni di
consumo nel 800 inglese era il carbone
nel novecento invece è il petrolio ma
non è cambiato molto il concetto è lo
stesso estraiamo dal sottosuolo la
materia che ci serve sia per costituire
prodotti sia per fornire l'energia
occorrente per la trasformazione delle
materie prime abbiamo un prodotto e
questo prodotto alla fine lo dobbiamo
smaltire perché il nostro concetto è che
il prodotto debba essere degradato
degradato a rifiuto a scarto in natura
non esiste niente analogo al rifiuto o
allo scarto quello che noi erroneamente
considereremmo rifiuto e scarto è
alimento e vieta per altre specie
viventi e vi voglio dimostrare che in
realtà se ci riflettessimo un attimo
equa la sigla il motto è ripensiamoci
ripensiamo anche al nostro ruolo alla
nostra condizione
e vero anche per noi che ci nutriamo di
scarti che cosa ci serve per
sopravvivere mangiare ovviamente il cibo
no quanto si può stare senza mangiare
senza cibo
qualche settimana senza bere qualche
giorno ma senza respirare quanto tempo
si può stare
solo qualche minuto dopo di che si
spengono le cellule del cervello
l'aria o meglio ancora l'ossigeno che
noi utilizziamo che cos'è lo sapete ve
lo dico e il sottoprodotto di un
processo che la fotosintesi
clorofilliana che svolgono le piante le
piante prendono la lead ride carbonica
effettivamente l'acqua e attraverso una
sostanza che è la clorofilla utilizzano
l'energia solare per produrre gli
zuccheri gli zuccheri sono l'alimento
della pianta ma sono anche l'alimento
degli animali erbivori che di quella
pianta si cibano e degli animali
carnivori che si cibano di quegli
animali erbivori il sottoprodotto di
questo processo lo scarto il rifiuto è
l'ossigeno
noi ci nutriamo dell'es cremento delle
piante facciamocene una ragione anche
noi siamo inseriti nel ciclo naturale e
guai se le piante non avessero questo
escremento lo seggio in un gas molto
reattivo e quindi tende a combinarsi
chimicamente con i prodotti che sono in
giro per la terra e dopo qualche mese
sarebbe completamente sottratto
all'atmosfera quindi se noi viviamo se
siamo qua e respiriamo e grazie agli
escrementi delle piante
perché questo discorso a che serve e
perché dobbiamo invece ripensare al
modello di sviluppo economico perché in
natura quello che facciamo noi non
esiste tutto quanto quello che è
utilizzato viene reinserito nel ciclo
quindi non c'è una testa e una coda ma
c'è un circolo è l'economia circolare
quello che noi considereremo rifiuto
diventa materia prima seconda viene
detta e poi dopo un altro ciclo materia
prima terza e così via materia prima
ennesima in un ciclo chiuso che richiede
soltanto energia e non richiede nuova
materia o nuovo cibo potremmo pensare
che allora se sia semplice inserire la
nostra e nostre attività produttive in
questo schema
in un certo senso in alcuni casi lo è se
prendiamo il vetro o prendiamo la
plastica o la carta noi che cosa
facciamo alla fine del ciclo produttivo
lo utilizziamo mandandolo al riciclo e
trasformando quella carta quell
alluminio quel vetro in un altro
prodotto ma ci avete mai riflettuto e
quasi un evento accidentale
mi ritrovo un barattolo che cosa faccio
lo butto ma no riutilizziamo lo non
avrebbe senso farne un altro ma se
prendiamo un telefonino o un computer o
un televisore ci sono tanti i materiali
preziosi per cui si sta violentando la
natura per cui ci sono dei veri forzati
in terra che estraggono questi materiali
preziosi per l'elettronica dalle viscere
della terra e noi non sappiamo cosa
farne
perché i prodotti non sono concepiti per
essere riciclabili e questa la pecca il
prodotto dovrebbe essere disegnato in
maniera tale che alla fine della sua
vita potesse essere smontato e
riutilizzato guai a continuare su questo
schema molte materie prime ormai sono in
esaurimento ed anche quelle che non sono
in esaurimento comportano comunque una
violenza sul territorio sul terreno da
cui vengono estratte che la terra non è
più in grado di sopportare
allora però tutti quanti questi prodotti
io voglio dimostrarvi che un prodotto in
particolare un dispositivo una macchina
ed in particolare l'auto elettrica
ci consente di ripensare al nostro
modello di mobilità dobbiamo ripensare
ripensare che significa rinunciare alla
comodità di un veicolo
ovviamente no nessuno sarebbe disposto
più ad andare a piedi oa dorso di mulo
sarebbe impensabile ma se abbiamo una
macchina perché questa macchina deve
essere incompatibile con le esigenze
ambientali
prendiamo questo sistema lo vedete
questo simula il funzionamento di un
motore a scoppio
sentite che rumore che fa questi sono
gli attriti che ci sono all'interno a
che serve tutto questo perché il pistone
va su e giù è un modo alternativo
lineare deve essere convertito invece
nel moto circolo
aree della ruota quindi significa che il
motore ruota non sono perfettamente
compatibili
prendiamo invece l'auto elettrica
facciamo la stessa cosa
sentire come silenziosa perché perché a
pochissimi attriti il motore elettrico
ruota esattamente come gli pneumatici
della macchina quindi si può mettere in
trazione diretta perciò non ha bisogno
di lubrificazione non ha bisogno di
tanti organi meccanici di conversione di
questi movimenti
andiamo avanti l'auto elettrica lo
sappiamo tutti e non mi soffermo non ha
emissioni quindi l'effetto serra
famigerato che invocavo prima nel caso
dell'auto elettrica se la produzione di
energia non comporta essa stessa
emissioni di anidride carbonica non ha
alcuna emissione di gas serra ma questo
è soltanto uno degli aspetti e non è
neanche l'aspetto principale bene voglio
dire un altro che invece molto più
preoccupante
nell'immediato per la nostra salute
soprattutto per chi vive nei grandi
centri urbani
il nostro sistema respiratorio è stato
plasmato dalla natura nel corso degli
anni dei secoli dei millenni dei milioni
di anni per filtrare tutte quante le
sostanze che non sono gassose e che
potrebbero accidentalmente arrivare
all'interno dei polmoni
immaginate che questo sia un alveo lo
polmonare
se accidentalmente una particella di
polvere viene inalata arriva sulla
superficie dell'alveo lo polmonare
eccolo qua però non fa grande anno
rimane galleggia sulla superficie le
polveri che sono emesse invece dai
motori a combustione interna dai motori
a scoppio e le polveri di metallo che
sono prodotti da questi attriti che vi
ho fatto vedere sono molto più
pericolose sono le polveri sottili o se
sono ancora più sottili di così
le nanoparticelle nano significa in
fisica un miliardesimo quindi significa
che sono particelle della dimensione di
un miliardesimo di metro cioè
pressappoco della stessa dimensione del
nostro
né a sé una granella di polvere sottile
arriva nei nostri polmoni guardate che
cosa fa gli alveoli polmonari hanno una
struttura spugnosa come questa piena di
anfratti la nanoparticella entra
all'interno dell'alveo lo polmonare e
disgraziatamente siccome l'alveo lo
polmonare è a contatto con flusso
sanguigno
da lì viene trasportato in ogni
distretto corporeo in ogni organo e la
cosa preoccupante è che alla fine
dell'anno scorso su una rivista
scientifica molto importante lancet è
stato stabilita la correlazione tra
l'insorgenza di malattie
neurodegenerative parkinson e alzheimer
e la concentrazione di polveri sottili
nell'ambiente che il soggetto in cui il
soggetto viveva ma non è ancora finita
qua prendiamo il caso di prima se
abbiamo un sistema frenante per le
macchine consuete le macchine
tradizionali
vi faccio vedere come funziona
immaginate lo sappiamo tutti d'altronde
che questo quasi alla ruota che gira
oppure il disco attaccato alla ruota il
sistema frenante funziona così 2 ganasce
si stringono e bloccano il disco che è
solidale con la ruota e convertono
l'energia di movimento della macchina in
energia termica in calore questo è il
sistema barbaro con cui le nostre
macchine frenano e quindi mentre nel
caso precedente
la parte la produzione di particelle
metalliche era un effetto collaterale
indesiderato il suo riscaldamento invece
del disco dei freni è un effetto
necessario perché soltanto in questa
maniera la macchina rallenta e allora
immettiamo all'interno dell'atmosfera
altre particelle metalliche con
l'aggravante che mentre le particelle
carboniose comunque hanno una
composizione a cui il nostro organismo
abituato perché sono simili a quelle
della che si sprigionano dalla
combustione ad esempio del legno di
particelle metalliche noi non abbiamo
alcuna esperienza le particelle
metalliche non sono in natura e quindi
quando arrivano nei polmoni il nostro
sistema immunitario non sa come reagire
di solito crea un infiammazione tentando
di distruggere quello che ritiene essere
un
per ion virus con il solo effetto di
aggravare la situazione perché alla fine
infiammazione dopo infiammazione sono le
cellule del corpo
a risentirne ed eventualmente a
degenerare c'è un altro modo
un altro mondo dei freni è possibile
ve lo dimostro mi metto a favore e
guardate faccio cadere una pallina di
plastica che è un diametro confrontabile
col diametro interno del tubo vado come
vedete niente di strano
cade per gravità ora prende invece
un'altra pallina di materiale metallico
che sia metallico ecco qua ve lo
dimostro perché riesco a sollevare
addirittura un barattolo
questo è un tubo di rame non c'è nessuna
attrazione eppure se io faccio cadere la
pallina all'interno va al rallentatore
non è magia e un effetto fisico è un
rallentamento magnetico non è un
rallentamento per attrito e quindi
significa che è possibile frenare gli
autoveicoli senza bisogno di utilizzare
il sistema dell'attrito e le macchine
elettriche hanno anche questo anno i
freni magnetici rigenerativi che
convertono l'energia di movimento in
nuova energia elettrica e che questo
particolato sia tutto quanto intorno a
noi ve lo faccio vedere con quest ultima
dimostrazione
qui c'è della polvere nel barattolo io
ho agito il barattolo e si vede che c'è
un po di pulviscolo dopodiché pensiamo
che il pulviscolo sia depositato e
quindi non possiamo più respirarlo uso
laser
guardate la luce del laser da sola non è
visibile quando invece lo faccio passare
attraverso il barattolo vedete
perfettamente che la luce diventa
visibile perché tutte le particelle che
sono tuttavia presenti ma che noi non
vediamo riflettono la luce del laser e
queste particelle per strada noi ce le
respiriamo
quindi la conclusione di questo discorso
è che l'economia circolare non soltanto
è una possibilità ma è una necessità e
un imperativo categorico ed esistono già
delle degli apparecchi degli strumenti
come la macchina elettrica che consente
di convertire questa teoria
pratica eccola la macchina elettrica
vedete è una macchina che si muove
azionata dalla luce del sole
in realtà è soltanto una simulazione ci
vorrebbe per muovere una macchina vera
un'automobile un pannello una
pannellatura solare grande quanto un
campo di tennis ma il concetto è
corretto perché si può utilizzare ad
esempio su grandi superfici ad esempio i
tetti di edifici dismessi come questi
che abbiamo visto qui a reggio emilia e
quella implicita utilizzarla per far
andare l'auto elettrica
perché l'auto elettrica non è un vezzo
l'auto elettrica è l'ultima l'ultimo
anello della catena dell'igiene
energetica produzione pulita di energia
d'utilizzazione altrettanto pulita e
quindi qual è la conclusione di questo
discorso è che noi siamo già senza
saperlo nell'era dell'economia circolare
questa è una rivoluzione in atto un
vento di cambiamento si sta sollevando e
un proverbio cinese dice che quando c'è
vento di cambiamento
sono due le disposizioni di spirito
possibili lo stolto innalza un muro per
proteggersi il saggio inizia a costruire
mulini a vento
grazie
[Musica]